the jogan experience the the real bad
thing is obviously forest fires forest
fires wildfires when those things get
going like entire towns are blanketed
with smoke for weeks yeah it was crazy I
mean I was in New York earlier this
summer or spring I think it was summer
and it was [__] wild you couldn't see
the buildings the weird thing was it was
like an orange color yeah and everybody
was speculating what are they burning
that was when the tin foil Hatters were
talking about like there's a bunch of
chemicals that were missing from some
train you know do you know about that
story there's some toxic chemicals that
we're missing like they're burning the
toxic chemicals up in Canada no I didn't
I miss I don't get a lot of the good
conspiracy theories how come baseball
talks in your head I'm all baseball I'm
soresi in baseball baby I like to live a
nice innocent life just good for you
cruising along good for you writing bits
watching watching sports this guy's
orange for whatever reason who cares
well cuz the sun is behind it this sun
and smoke so it makes orange the sun is
orange I've
colored it's a big I've never seen that
orang yellow whatever I've never seen
forest fires that orange the sun's not
yellow it's chicken it's white it's
white Bob Dy it's white what is the sun
yeah yeah it's a it's what you're
getting through the blue of the sky and
all the that's what makes it look yellow
well whatever that's another conspiracy
theory but the um that orange smoke show
me some photos of what that looks like
the the smoke that was in New York City
cuz it looks crazy crazy orange like
like almost like like you're like you're
burning Cheetos but isn't the sunset is
orange so the sun setting and you get
smoke and so it becomes
orangey maybe but I don't think it was
during sunset that this was happening so
what do you think like people ran down
and threw chemicals in the fire no I
think it might be just the whatever the
kind of wood that's burning what kind of
you know what's getting burnt I don't
know I don't I have really have no idea
right you ever see how many [__]
trees are in Canada there's a lot of
trees there's like some that's what it
looked like some amount of billion trees
so this is 1:30 p.m. 1:45 p.m. 2 p.m.
that's unusual dude yeah that's not just
the sun that's unusual whatever the [__]
that is that's very unusual for it to
look like that go to go to the last part
of the frame
Jimmy so this is what it looks like as
it blows in at 11:30 12:30 31 115 130
145 like right there stop at two yeah
that's bad that's not normal no that's a
dark orange at 2 p.m. so that's not like
Sunset it's weird I mean I don't know
why that smoke is
orange but it's [__] weird so that's
when the conspiracy theories come in
right they there's hundreds of thousands
of gallons mixed they're trying to
poison us depopulate
do you believe it no I don't believe it
but I don't know I mean I don't know if
something else burnt up there they're
not telling us about right I mean it's
Canada yeah you never know you trust
them who Canadians I trust the people I
like hockey I like hockey too I like the
people people are awesome yeah they're
the best the people running the country
that are a problem I don't really know
much I think we should build a wall [__]
it let's do it build a wall got a lot of
wood it's all wood up there if it
catches fire though it'll be like so
[__] orange just make a ditch next to
the wood so that fire doesn't spread
that's not bad I love Canada and there's
I think there's I looked it up one time
cuz my father-in-law once said there was
like he go there must be two trillion
trees in the world what do you think the
number is in the whole world
yeah I think he went High I believe it's
less than that I'm going to say 1.7
trillion tray I think it's like it's a
total guess though I think it's in the
billions I'm going to say it's like 400
billion trees I bet it's more than that
I think I remember but I also thought
[__] that lady had a mustache so
you're both wrong what is it 3.04
trillion wow wow it's more oh maybe I
see I knew he was off but really he went
low wow well maybe when he said it it
was that number I mean this was like
three years ago well this's the thing
this is the like this is the crazy thing
about this whole climate change uh
discussion and one of the things that
people conveniently like to uh ignore
this is the like one of the greenest
periods in recorded
history when you think like we're
cutting down all the trees and there's
less trees there's less green than ever
before right no carbon dioxide is food
for plants right and there's more plants
now than there there have been in the
last like 20 plus years what what is the
when they say The Greening of Earth
because of climate change Google that
like what percentage more uh green is
the Earth today than than 50 years ago
is that probably because there's more
rain and [__] or what more carbon
dioxide right yeah literally it's food
for them but there's huge forest fires
all all these places like Greece that
they didn't used to be yeah but that was
man-made that's this is the other thing
they keep talking about with all this
climate change stuff yeah there's
definitely been forest fires but a [__]
ton of them are man-made a [__] ton of
them are
accidents the one in Hawaii power lines
fell over it's a lot of it's bad
maintenance the the Hawaii one's
definitely bad m instant and chop down
the the dry grass near the power lines
they also need to bury power lines
that's [__] stupid and especially
places you got high winds bury your
[__] power lines you know like look
look what happened and the United States
should take care of that too by the way
right and then there's also uh Forest
management like you're supposed to go
into these forests and take out all the
dead wood right controlled Burns and all
that [__] yeah but they have to take it
out they remove it and it's valuable
they can do stuff with that wood right
so they need to log the dead wood out of
the forest and they need they need
like they were talking about that during
the Trump Administration and he was
blaming some of the fires that were
having in California and poor poor
um poor management of the
forests and and then I was like that
sounds like a ridiculous thing and then
I talked to a guy who's actually works
with wildlife biology and he's like it's
it's really critical to do right like
that's why they do control burns that's
why they do get rid of you know dead
wood like if you don't do it
and then you have something comes in
like a the bark Beetle and it kills like
a giant percentage of the trees carbon
dioxide fertilization Greening Earth
study finds from a quarter to half of
Earth's vegetated lands have showed
significant Greening over the last 35
years largely due to the rising levels
of atmospheric carbon dioxide according
to a new study published in the Journal
of nature climate change in April of
25 um April 25th rather international
team of 32 off ERS in 24 institutions in
eight countries led the effort which
involved using satellite data from
NASA's modern moderate resolution
imaging spectometer oh that sounds cool
and the National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration Advanced very high
resolution radiometer instruments to
help determine the leaf area index or
amount of Leaf cover over the planet's
vegetated regions The Greening
represents an increase in leaves on
plants and trees equivalent in an area
to two times the continental United
States great yeah they don't say that
because if they say that then people go
well wait is not better is not good shut
up climate change is bad and you need to
go electric are you not scared of
climate change and all the high
temperatures and all that [__] the
storms and the fires and all that
business I'm always concerned about
weather because it's unpredictable and
the thing about climate
change is there's for sure humans are
affecting it
to deny that seems crazy we're [__]
burning fossil fuels but also it's never
been stable like ever in history right
in the the history of the earth it's
always done this crazy [__] and there's
been massive ice ages where we weren't
burning nothing and then there's been
like the dinosaur times where it was way
[__] hotter and there's been times on
Earth where there was no ice in the
polar caps and there's been times on
Earth where there's way more and half of
North America was covered over a mile of
ice right
so we'll be all right I'm scared of ice
ages dude no we'll be fine yeah maybe
but that's the thing to be scared of
really yeah yeah I feel like I I I hear
a lot more concerned scientists about
you know heat T ni right because that's
the uh subject dour that's the thing you
worry about more than terrorism right
but this isn't I'm not talking like NBC
I'm talking like NASA [__] Stephen
Hawking I know he's dead but you know I
don't think he was on the climate change
thing he's paying attention much more to
the whole universe I think but he was
worried about it I think I heard him
mention it somewhere or I hear him but
you know what I mean read concern like
if the Earth gets warmer it is a concern
um but if the Earth gets cooler that's a
concern too sure it's it's just like
life on Earth is like insanely
unpredictable you know and uh they
definitely need to figure out what kind
of an effect we're having on it but they
need to be like completely honest about
what they know and what the data shows
and what the problem is and how to fix
it right for sure the pro there's a
pollution problem for sure like the fact
that we ignore what we're doing in the
ocean is crazy yeah that's what I always
thought it's like even if you're like
not concerned with climate change like
well aren't you interested in making the
air cleaner and the water I mean
shouldn't we be have a cleaner place to
live 100% that should be everybody's
concerned like to eliminate pollution